THE PRESIDENT STRUCK A
MODERATE TONE OR SEEMED TO.
SOME CONGRESSIONAL
>> CHAIN MIGRATION IS SO
INSIDIOUS IT IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL FLAW IN
IMMIGRATION POLICY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IF ANY CONVERSATION ABOUT
DACA IS BEING HELD WITHOUT
THAT CONSIDERATION, I AGREE
WITH BORDER SECURITY AS
WELL, BUT ANY CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT IS NOT GOING TO
GO ANYWHERE IN THE UNITED
NEWS SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST AND FOR GOOD REASON
HE JOINS US TO ASSESS
TODAY'S EVENT.
HEY, BRIT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> I'M THE OLDEST GUY,
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: WELL, THERE IS
THAT.
>> SOME PEOPLE WOULD SAY
SENIOR MOMENT POLITICAL
EARNED IT.
>> IT LOOKED FOR A MOMENT --
PRESIDENT HIMSELF HAD HAD A
EARLIER SAID THAT SHE WAS
HOPING A CLEAN BILL ON DACA
FIX THAT IS TO SAY THE BILL
TO LET THE DREAMERS HERE
LEGALLY STAY IN THE COUNTRY
AND THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT'S WHAT HE WANTED, TOO.
WHERE UPON IT BECAME CLEAR
TO THE REPUBLICANS SITTING
AROUND THE TABLE THAT THAT
REALLY ISN'T WHAT MR. TRUMP
UNDERSTOOD BY A CLEAN BILL
AND KEVIN MCCARTHY, THE
SHE MEANS BY THAT SHE MEANS
A BILL DACA ONLY.
SHE SAYS OH NO, I DON'T MEAN
THAT.
DACA WITH THE ADDITIONAL
SECURITY MEASURES WHICH IS
FUNDING FOR THE WALL AND END
TO CHAIN MIGRATION AND HE
ADDED AN END TO THE LOTTERY
ON ON THE SOUND BITE YOU
JUST PLAYED.
BY THE TIME ALL WAS SAID AND
DONE ON, THIS THE PRESIDENT
HAD DEMONSTRATED HE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT ALL OF US
AROUND WASHINGTON WELL KNOWN
TERM CLEAN BILL HE DID NOT
CHANGE HIS POSITION ON THE
ISSUE.
GENERAL ARE TO THE RIGHT OF
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE OF SOME
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS AND
CERTAINLY LARGE NUMBER OF
REPUBLICAN VOTERS AND THESE
ARE PRECISELY, OF COURSE,
THE VOTERS WHO SUPPORTED
AND, YOU KNOW, WHICH HE
SUGGESTED NOT ONLY DO WE
GET CONTROL OF LEGAL
IMMIGRATION AS WELL.
THAT'S SORT OF WHERE HE CAME
OUT ON THIS TODAY.
I MIGHT ADD, TUCKER.
WHAT WAS INTERESTING ABOUT
THIS RESPONSE TO THE SESSION
TODAY PRESIDENT DID
LEADERS OF BOTH PARTIES WITH
THE CAMERAS ROLLING.
YOU JUST DON'T SEE THAT VERY
OFTEN AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
THE KIND OF THING THAT WOULD
SQUARE VERY WELL WITH THE
DESCRIPTION OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN THIS MOST RECENT
BOOK ABOUT SUCH A SENSATION
AND NEVER LISTENS TO
BRIEFINGS.
HE SEEMED PRETTY WELL
BRIEFED ON THESE ISSUES AND
SPOKE OF THEM WITH SOME
FLUENCY AND IN GENERAL, I
LOOKING AT THAT WOULD GIVE
HIM A PRETTY HIGH MARKS ON
IT.
>> Tucker: SO DO YOU THINK
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT HIS
PRIVATE POSTURE WILL BE
DIFFERENT ON THE ISSUES, ON
THE SPECIFICS OF BORDER
WE SAW TODAY IN THE PUBLIC
MEETING?
, I THINK BY THE TIME THE
PUBLIC MEETING WAS OVER HIS
POSTURE WAS THE SAME AS WHAT
WE HAVE HEARD HIM SAY
BEFORE.
HE WANTS TO DO DACA.
LET THE DREAMERS STAY HERE.
HE WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT BUT
HE IS GOING TO INSIST ON
GETTING SOME SECURITY
MEASURES AS PART OF ANY
LEGISLATION TO DO THAT.  AND
THE QUESTION THEN BECOMES,
ASKED FOR BORDER WALL,
MONEY, END OF CHAIN
MIGRATION AND AN END TO THE
LOTTERY SYSTEM WILL BE BE
ABLE TO GET AND WHEN IT GETS
DOWN TO IT, WOULD HE REJECT
A BILL THAT DIDN'T HAVE AS
MUCH AS HE WANTED AS HE IS
SEEKING.
I DON'T THINK WE KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT.
THAT AT LEAST IS THE
POSITION HE HAS STAKED OUT.